alors bienvenue à l'association alter
ego musée des mines imaginaire vu la
chaleur qu'il ya aujourd'hui je vous
propose d'aller directement voir la
référer où je vous donnerai des
explications aux offres silence
bienvenue dans l'univers de l'art et
ferré réseau ferré réunis par son
directeur en chef alain phrase
cet ancien chercheur à l'inra
spécialiste des insectes détourne les
techniques du modélisme depuis près de
15 ans pour créer un univers qui allie
austérité et fantaisie débridée
le récit complice de joël wailly donne à
ce monde minuscule une véracité
troublante
tout ici que fait son plan sans dessin
sans prévisualisation tout est en carton
nous sommes au en 87e c'est à dire qu'on
est au à peu près de 2 cm la première
maquette que j'ai vu quand j'ai
rencontré alain c'est celle ci l'asaf
académie des sciences et des arts
ferroviaire ici donc on apprend à
construire les trains et d'après
monsieur fraval il ay ay si le plus beau
métier du monde
essayeur de sièges et surtout partout à
la référer rien ne ressemble à la
réalité c'est très important
et puis on voit que c'est de la
récupération en même temps que du carton
on a de la paille à boire pour les
tuyaux et on a des corps de stylo qui
forment des grues et je pense que
monsieur fraval a dû collecter ses 30
ans dînera au stylo c'est vrai il ya
quelque chose d'extraordinaire ici c'est
la récupération des caisses de wagons
pour faire des locaux supplémentaires
pour l'asaf donc quand il y en a 1 2 3 4
5 ça devient un wagon ville et donc
ensuite nous avons l'eau à 6 milliards
mais le resto pourquoi
parce que le dire chef estime que s'il y
avait eu un tex-mex ou un mac do
personne ne serait à son poste donc le
petit train jaune là bas bien se faire
remplir dessus et s'en sert à vittel
tout le monde à ce poste
la suivante et le nucléaire ou heroes
chimie par contre comme tout est fait
sans plan et sans pré visualisation le
dire cheikh n'avait pas prévu cette
immonde tu as là surtout que ce tas il
cache le ministère de la culture
or alain et moi sommes bien placés pour
savoir qu avoir des subventions
culturelles est très difficile à l'infra
val qui a toujours des solutions
magnifique en tant que dit le chef
extraordinaire s'est dit je vais
demander des subventions pour le
nucléaire ça on est sûr de les avoir et
en effet il a eu les subventions comme
il avait promis un jour de faire le
printemps de la référer il a fait et
donc nous sommes arrivés sur les houches
donc ici on fait de l'art parce que
comment faire autrement dans un monde
pollué et des végétalisée peut faire de
l'art pour figurer un jardin ici il ya
quelque chose d'extrêmement important
qui est l'atelier balayette juste au
dessus on voit bien les travailleurs à
l'oeuvre avec du ballet de la balayette
du pinceau du blaireau et quelques fils
électriques
ils ont réussi à faire un très joli
jardin d'ailleurs le dire chef est
tellement content qu'il aura fait un
petit kiosque pour se reposer et l'a
même poussé le bouchon là jusqu'à une
piscine mais il ya bien marqué comme
avant donc comme elle est entièrement
polluer personnes les mets les pieds bon
vous voyez là il ya quand même quelques
amoureux mc c'est parfaitement
imaginaire puisqu'ils ont une libido mes
personnages je les ai mis ils ont pas
droit de bouger
et nous arrivons donc à la cave de l'opi
l'office pour les insectes et leur
environnement dont monsieur fraval est
encore rédac de recherche d'une rue
corédacteur je pense il n'y a que des
insectes artificielle de deux catégories
les mouches pour la pêche et les
insectes sur lesquels on colle une puce
électronique pour espionne passons c'est
le créateur c'est le créateur s'est
dirigé sur les houches voyait tout cette
variété d'installations s'était
reproduit à paris c'est la promenade
plantée qui lie à la bastille si vous
connaissez ce soit se sont inspirés de
10 et à new york la mite line une
ancienne ligne ferroviaire qui
desservaient des abattoirs est
maintenant entièrement végétalisée et
parsemer le statut et d'installation
paris le musée des mondes imaginaires
vous accueille du mardi au dimanche de
15h à 19h